nous avons regardé s'envoler
les enfants non
il monte
ah ah
la maison défia ce parce que la maison
est vieille il passe par les petites
routes sur le côté du volet et ils font
à peu près ont offert 50 à 60 me par
jour et on peut enfin viadeo servait
tellement envahissant qu'on enlève les
nids et quatre heures après diana nous
il ya 18 on sait pas comment ils font
mais il ya je parle de vous faire au
moins 109 par jour une marguerite entre
les dents lorsqu'elle met vite nous
obstinément les même l'habitude liard la
petite julia existait au début ici quand
on est arrivé on avait une une petite
chèvres des moutons etc tout ça a été
lâché et puis tout ça était en liberté
et puis elle avait pris l'habitude de
venir
manger avec plus loin table elle venait
parler fonctionner comme ça et puis on
lui donner du pain et caetera et jours/7
et l'hiver il a fait froid
et puis les portes fenêtres étaient
fermées mais elle l a pas tellement
compris alors fait de la prison et la
porsche n est pas elle est rentrée dans
20 ou 30 ans la foire ça l'a vu un du
monde sur dur avec des cordes et puis
voilà on a compris que c'était un peu
difficile d'avoir des chèvres parce
qu'il s'échappe tout le temps finalement
maintenant elle va plus
actuellement il à chaque fois une
cinquantaine peut-être mais qui a pas
longtemps mais c'est le fait que je
renouvelle tout le cheptel
voyez cette charmante demoiselle qui
s'appelle geagea et aidé par par le gros
l'euro machin qui mène son fils qui
s'appelle lutte qui est un saint bernard
qui fait 120 kg et un troisième larron
qui était boxer qui avait sept huit mois
à peu près monfils a oublié de de fermer
les pouilles d'enfermer les poules la
veille au soir et il ya quelques tomes
salle le matin la trouver 120 cadavres
de canaan poule à peu présents dans le
champ les chiens il y en a plus que
trois maintenant on en avait 19 et pas
tellement longtemps
alors il n'ya plus que monsieur n'à pour
que moi aussi sa fiancée jascha voilà
oui voilà autres eh bien oui d'accord
oui qu'est ce que tu me racontes oui tu
voudrais bien aller aux couleurs oui
elle me dit et je m'en ferais bien
quelques une de plus alors là quand de
grands soucis avec la peau parce que
comme c'était le chien de la maison qui
se dit quand il a vu grossir le mal a
commencé à prendre le dessus et il a
attaqué à mort n'étant que l'autre était
bébé ça allait un peu mieux maintenant
que l'autre mais quatre fois son poids
n'autorise son filet
dérouillée toulouse
celui-là est resté sur le carreau les
moustaches endroit ils avaient tous à
d'ouvert il lui manquait deux tabourets
enfin c'était dramatique et notre sueur
du sang partout pas la fourrure et tout
le territoire venez voter faut pas les
laisser en présence et de dire vous avez
vu des câlins kehl à l'autre matin s'en
va très sagement au lieu de voir
dialogue le canasson c'est une autre
affaire le ebeam vie moment de pacha
parce que personne ne monte maintenant
alors là il est là il est comme un pacha
ebay kt tout ce qui peut toute la
journée malus il a fallu d'ailleurs que
j'ai juste demandé aux jardiniers là qui
s'occupe un peu de ça de son avoine de
patin viendrait parce qu'il n'avait pas
compris que le cheval étant toutes ses
journées à la prairie
ils arrêtent emplois non de briefer ça
lui suffisait amplement le soir il y
donnait ou plus une botte de machin plus
un saut de granulés compaq d'herbe et
tout ça à manger savait qu'il s'était un
bourrin énorme alors on l'a un peu
diminué mais il est lâché toute l'année
est en liberté
on a à peu près 2 hectares de prairies
d'herbes et tout ça est alors très
pratique pour regarder le vent de la mer
est très difficile d'avoir des animaux
je ne je n'espère pas avoir d'autres
animaux parce que il faut s'en occuper
très bien parce que à partir du mois de
mai juin ici voyez derrière les 3es mena
les salopards ils viennent ils me
s'agrippe à la grille quand ils partent
en vacances et me valence les chiens par
dessus la grille est ici tous les étés
on en recueille 3 4 5
il est l'ancien lula qui avait été un
beau chien d'ailleurs qui avait été
balancé la vers le mois de mai juin et
puis on a vu quelqu'un revenir super
septembre retors enfin après les
vacances certainement qui a peut être
garder son chien qui est venu de nous
aider mon chien super du tout ça c'était
pas vrai dire ce qu'il avait vraiment
balancé pour s'en débarrasser pendant
les vacances et alors gibel bien sûr et
saisiront la trouver là il était un peu
famille et on vous le rang et on l'a
rendu et les gens habitaient je prends
une cinquantaine de kilomètres d'ici
emmené le chien ils ont le même intérêt
chez intervenus il valait plus de sa
maison ouvrez ouvrez la cage aux oiseaux
regardez les s'envoler
et
les enfants c'est mon poignet
quelle joie aux prisonniers ouvrez leur
la porte de mai
arrêté
et ouvrez la cage aux oiseaux
regardez les sens
go
les enfants